Iteration seems like a very
specific process for most products.
I mean, entrepreneurs,
you need to analyze data and
act accordingly to improve your
specific monetization model.
And it can vary a lot by product.
But are there any instances where we can
provide specific, actionable tips for
a given product?
>> Actually yes, companies in the game
industry seems to follow a few
proven paths for increasing revenue.
First, promote certain items at
the right situation for heavy gamers.
The challenge here is to
identify these players and
to find the right situations.
Second, offer an item
with a big discount
only to the potential paid users.
The challenge is to
segment these users and
control the exposure of this discount.
Third, use ads for non paying users.
The challenge is to blend the ads and
protect the experience so
the users will still love the game.
>> And for everyone else we've
got some key takeaways for
this lesson in the next video.